the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another update video
as i'm sure most of you know already i
have been writing my own version of game
of thrones season nine
i recently released my fourth episode
and i am currently working on my fifth
i am making these videos because i know
a lot of fans were not happy with how
game of thrones ended
hopefully i will have the following
episode done soon so be on the lookout
for that
in this video i want to discuss some of
the recent news surrounding george rr
martin
and the upcoming game of thrones
successor show house of the dragon
this information was actually released
from the man the myth the legend himself
george r.r martin let's have a look at
his not a blog website where he gave us
the update
according to george hbo has hired
another actor for their new series house
of the dragon
george said he is the common born son of
the steward to the lord of black haven
he has no claim or lands or titles all
he has
is his honor and his skill with sword
and lands
he is a challenger a champion cheered by
the commons
beloved of the ladies he is a lover or
is he
a seducer or is he a betrayer
or is he a breaker of hearts and a maker
of kings
fire and blood readers know him as sir
kristen cole
house of the dragon viewers will know
him as fabian frankel
the actor listed below welcome to
westeros fabian
and do keep that sword sharp alright
ladies and gentlemen
we now know who will be our sir
christian cole who eventually becomes
the lord commander of the kingsguard to
king aegon targaryen
the second of his name now some of you
may or may not remember
but there was a different actor who was
auditioning to be this character
a few months ago i released a video
where i showed another actor reading
some lines for this character
in an audition video that was leaked
online now because of that video
i received my first copyright strike not
only that but hbo had my whole video
taken down so no one else would see it
i believe the actor's name is feroz
durrani
some of you should remember seeing that
video before hbo had it removed
the reason why i am mentioning this is
because i know a lot of you did not like
that actor
or at least not his audition well now
you don't have to worry
because he did not get the job i do not
recognize this actor
fabian frankel who did get the job so
i'm not sure how good he will be either
the way i see it is hbo did an amazing
job at casting game of thrones so i have
faith they will get great actors and
actresses for house of the dragon as
well
now if you have seen some of this
actor's work let me know what you think
of him down below
i am always interested in seeing what
all of you have to say
there were some whispers that house of
the dragon would begin filming on april
15th which was only a few days ago
i haven't seen any new updates or
developments about this as of yet
so i still don't know if filming has
begun whenever filming does actually
begin
there will start to be lots of photos
and videos leaked from the different
sets
which i will make videos on anytime i
get my hands on them
so be on the lookout for those as well
now i want to show you what else george
rr martin said
on his not a blog website because some
of you might find it to be interesting
depending on how you look at it first i
just want to give nerd roddick a shout
out
i did not know george even made this
update until i saw his video
now there are some fans who think this
next update
might mean that george r martin is
finished with the winds of winter
since the message is from george himself
you're gonna have to read between the
lines to figure out exactly what he
means by this
chances are it doesn't mean anything but
hey we can all dream of spring
can't we let me show you what he said
way back when on live journal
when i started this column or journal or
whatever it is
i named it my not a blog because i could
see that regular blogging was a lot of
work
and i didn't think i had the time to
devote to it i was late on a book even
then
though i do not recall which one i
figured i would just give some updates
from time to time
when i had an important announcement
when the mood struck me or whatever
somehow though over the decades the nada
blog became a blog
and what i had intended as an occasional
pleasure and a way to stay in touch with
my readers
has become a blog ironically at the same
time as everyone else was abandoning
their blogs for facebook
complete with a sense of obligation and
when a lot of stuff happens
very fast i fall further and further
behind
i am hugely behind right now and the
thought of trying to catch up is feeling
increasingly oppressive
my life has become one of extremes these
last few months
some days i do not know whether to cry
or laugh to shoot off fireworks and
dance in the streets
or crawl back into bed and lift the
covers over my head
the good stuff that has been happening
to me has been very very very good
the kind of thing that will make a year
or a career
but the bad stuff that is happening has
been very very very bad
and it is hard to cherish the good and
feel the joy when the shadows are all
around
if any of you read the stories about me
on the internet you will know my good
news
i have a new 5-year deal with hbo to
create
new game of thrones successor shows and
some non-related series like road marks
for both hbo and hbo max it's an
incredible deal
an amazing deal very exciting and i want
to tell you all about it
although it seems that the media has
already done that there's already
stories in all the trades
you can read about it here these days i
almost never get to break any news about
myself
some of their stories are even accurate
i will blog about it
i expect but not today there's lots more
happening as well
meow wolf stuff railroad stuff beastly
books has reopened
but the jcc is still shuttered the jets
traded sam darnold away
i am going to be leaving my cabin in a
couple of months
i am close to delivering a brand new
wild cards book
i will tell you about some of this i
guess but not today
now if you're sane and you have your
wits about you
you will look at this and think this
doesn't really mean anything
other than exactly what he said if
you've lost your damn mind
like me and a lot of the other fans who
are hopeful you will look at this and
wonder what does george really mean when
he says
he is leaving his cabin in only a few
months
for those of you that don't know this is
where he locked himself away
so he could finish the winds of winter
so this makes me wonder
is he done with the book or almost done
since he's about to leave the cabin
honestly who knows the whole reason for
him giving this update was to tell us
how he is behind on all of his work
like he always is another thing that
some fans have found interesting is the
photo he shared with this update
now if you look right here under the
date there is an image of the stark
direwolf
in their house words winter is coming
now what does that mean
we're getting ready to head into the
summer so i know he's definitely not
referring to the weather
maybe this is a reference to more delays
because he did say he is behind on his
work
we all know the winds of winter should
have been released years ago
these delays have been happening for the
last five or six years at least
or maybe just maybe since he will be
leaving the cabin soon
that means the winds of winter is coming
deep down
i think we all hope that's what it would
mean but is that likely
well i will leave that for you to decide
by now
i think we're more likely to get detox
from dr dre
than we are to get the winds of winter
from george rr martin
then again i know nothing now if you do
want to see how game of thrones should
have ended
make sure you check out all of the
season 9 videos on my channel
i will be releasing more episodes very
soon
as always i want to thank everyone for
watching my video
i hope all of you have a great day i'll
see you soon
bye
[Music]
you